fear is a motivator in the micro short
term it is the most disgusting weapon
that a human can use if you don't know
how to solve this figure it out
I think about leadership from this
concept of gray not black or white most
leaders are going to be either black or
white it's not Empire of honey it's
honey Empire nothing works unless
there's Humanity the number one job of a
leader
is to eliminate fear the reason we call
it the Honey Empire when we talk about
leadership is you get more out of honey
than vinegar you may get short-term wins
in vinegar but you will not get
sustained winds with vinegar then
there's the opposite side the me that
everything's bubble gum and rainbows and
you're putting it all on you but you're
quietly building resentment you have to
work on what I've worked on for the last
five years
which is the ability to deliver what we
call kind Candor but I realize that
Candor that corporations love to stand
up was really for a lot of people an
excuse to be mean an excuse to control
someone that they're managing so that
they don't Propel you know how much
human psychology goes into a manager
that consciously knows the person
they're managing is more talented than
them there's a subconscious repression
going on there because they don't want
it to happen
so Candor all of a sudden became
manipulation
Candor I always really struggled with
somehow some way because I was working
on myself I sold myself on the concept
of this term called kind Candor and has
transformed our company because what was
happening for us was
you know I'm the CEO of the company I'm
the founder of the company so you're
listening to me for 10 minutes here I
think you're getting a sense of how we
roll the problem is we were on the
opposite side we created unlimited
entitlement if nobody's getting any
critical feedback and nobody's allowed
to say anything to anybody it went the
other way
we were two over here I genuinely
believe that every single thing at
vaynerx all 1900 people that every
single thing that isn't working is 100
my fault
I really believe that's leadership
here's why
I could be mad at project management my
hired the head of production management
the CEO did I hired the clo
like there you have to fall in love with
accountability if you have any interest
in leadership
you have to fall in love with it and
most people don't want it especially now
pop culture right now is in love with
pointing fingers everything's about
pointing fingers
most of us here looking around we've all
now are deep in our understanding of all
the things our parents up on
it's like say right like we are in deep
knowledge of every thought we have about
Mom and Dad right now my question is
like when does that stop
great agreed inconceivable that someone
is sitting here that doesn't have
thoughts about that my question is at
what age do you take control and fix it
for you
and that's how I think about leadership
I think there's such an opportunity if
we just get real about it and find that
middle
there is incredible
happiness that comes along with 100
accountability
because you feel like you're in control
all of it is stemming on the same thing
if you don't feel like you're in control
as a human being you were unhappy the
leadership of your own self
starts to become the practice that you
can deploy for others every single thing
I'm disappointed with my default in my
brain goes into how did I not put this
person in a position to succeed so that
is now leading to the thing I'm
frustrated about what didn't I do your
own pain and frustration you're
deploying on others
right so that's what you're bringing to
the meetings and the energy
we just have to find a way to get all
that poison out
you've got to get it out that's all it
ever is it's just beer
and fear has been weaponized at scale in
society and so it's become normalized
subconsciously life is about
interpretation
tactics will not work for leadership
intent will do you actually give a
about people
do you or is everything that you're
doing completely predicated on the
short-term monetary needs you have for
the expenses you've created for yourself
that's the question about
leadership
and I think leadership
has to really have a serious
conversation of human truths not that
the slang words that are starting to
emerge
the actual truth of what we're actually
talking out here
thank you
foreign